hey Doug Walker here um monetization is
back yeah um when our video went up last
night they said the monetization is back
it took a while for it to hit all the
videos is only the new ones after the
strike but but now it's it's all back
the we're pretty much back in business
less than a day after that video aired
so what does this mean it means a couple
of things the most important thing is
expressing how thankful we are to
everybody who went out there and shared
this this shows not only do you want to
see us do more content stuff like that
but you are just as involved and
concerned about what YouTube is doing as
we are and you want to get it out there
and just everybody really bottom of our
hearts thank you so much I mean we
really could not be more thankful you
guys did in less than a day what we
couldn't do going through the official
you to support in three weeks the strike
is still on our account and we're still
in the process of getting it removed but
that's part of the process we expected
and we're used to going through but
here's also what it means
YouTube has given us no answer why this
happened and why does it take people
going public to get this stuff fixed why
isn't it being done the normal route
that says on their website that should
be done as professionally as any other
business one of the things we heard a
lot from people because we did a lot of
phone calls and stuff last night from
other people either in similar
situations or have come across this
before YouTube YouTube content creators
and stuff one of the things we heard
constantly is that we're all in this
together and they are absolutely right
any channel can still be hit it doesn't
matter what size they can have their
monetization taken away they can hit B
suspend it they can have their whole
entire channel deleted and you don't
have to be given a reason this is still
going on with so many people that have
come out before us and after as an the
more attention that we're getting to the
people they're being treated unfairly
with this process we really don't want
to see this as well we're done that's
the end of that we've
very much want to see this as the start
the start of some sort of big change
going on to start a dialogue the start
of changing these problems getting them
fixed one of the biggest things the
internet has shown is that there's power
in the community and right now for
whatever reason if you want to be heard
you have to go public if you've been
wronged by YouTube through some sort of
fair use claim and it is clearly in fair
use and anybody can see it go out there
go public and talk about it get a
dialogue going and let people know let
YouTube know that this is going on and
this is not fair and this needs to be
fixed now here's the thing we know not
everybody has the amount of viewership
that we have some of more some have less
and they're not going to get as big
attention like what we got so down the
road we're going to do more videos
addressing this issue I mean we're not
gonna all the videos aren't going to be
screwed into videos or anything like
that don't worry but we are gonna do
more videos talking about these issues
going on the issues that we come across
and the issues that you're going through
right now we're not going away a lot of
content creators are going away either
they're going to keep using fair use
because it's our right it's in the law
it's clear for anyone to see and you're
not going away either you're going to
keep creating content you're going to
keep watching it and we need to make it
clear we're here to stay there's a court
case lens versus Universal that happened
last year where the judge ruled that
fair use has to be taken into
consideration before the claimant can
issue the takedown and that's not being
done the system in place right now was
created to protect the content creators
on YouTube but now it's being used to
abuse them and there are no penalties
for false claims that is a huge problem
why do the content creators get
penalized when the people who issue the
false claims had nothing happened to
them these are the serious problems that
need to be addressed and we're going to
go into further in upcoming videos but
right now we're just trying to get
things back on track and finally people
asked us if we can set up a patreon or
if they can donate to PayPal because of
everything that's happened and is kind
and generous as that is everybody we're
going to be okay we did lose a good
chunk of money but we're going to be ok
a if you're still looking to donate
though please give it to one of our
favorite charities one-step camp or EF F
both of them do wonderful work they're
definitely worth checking out so please
definitely go and see the great stuff
that they do guys I really mean it when
I say this should not be the end this
should be the beginning beginning of
getting some real change going and some
real dialog and go out there and make
your voices heard because enough is
enough and we got to get this rolling so
thank you all so much for your support
again we could not be more thankful
let's really make some change happen